still see falling blocks in my dreams
Tetris who knew a retro 80s game had
such an exciting and honestly scary
story behind it I'm gonna be taking you
behind the scenes so you can find out
exactly what's real and what's fiction
the laws that Hank Rogers brought to the
Soviet Union that almost landed him in a
gulag and of course the inevitable
impact that kovid had on this film Taren
egerton plays Hank Rogers in Tetris and
after reading the script he was
astounded at everything that went on
surrounding the game in the 80s he had
to take a lot of advice from Hank when
it came to his single-mindedness and
ambition I am not going home without a
deal because truly who would do what he
did but yeah apparently the film is
emotionally accurate to who these
characters are so it was important for
Taran to capture that within his
performance it also didn't hurt that he
got to play a ton of Tetris and call it
work these are the things I get paid to
do you know speaking of accuracy let's
talk about everything the movie got
right my feelings and the anxiety
variety of you know having to to end up
in the Soviet Union Hank was filled with
anxiety mostly because he was breaking a
ton of laws entering a government
structure without invite is highly legal
and knew it really didn't know whether I
was going to end up in a gulag or what
it just was a little scary also the fact
that Alexi had no idea what
repercussions were going to be faced
when he was working on what he calls his
little baby Tetris when the director
John S Baird first read the script he
was shocked at how little was actually
fiction when I realized it was true I
thought I have to make this movie his
motivation when directing the film was
to make the audience feel the way he did
when he first read it utterly shocked at
the amount of danger Hank and Alexi put
themselves in over Tetris the burning
question we're all dying to ask was
taryn's mustache real the mustache that
God gave me is a little lacking so
that's a movie hell I don't know about
you guys but I've never worn a fake
mustache that's a fake mustache so I had
no idea how brutal it was apparently
Taryn wore a fake mustache for part of
the film during Eddie the eagle and he
vowed to never put one on again but a
bit like childbirth I forgot so yeah the
mustache totally fake and apparently
absolutely uncomfortable Karen vows yet
again that he will never put on one for
the rest of his life doesn't matter how
much you pay me don't let me wear a fake
mustache friendship is a huge theme of
this movie primarily between Hank and
Alexi Hank was the first person Alexi
could ever talk with about computers why
can't both lines disappear at once
instead of one at a time I never thought
of that
considering we're in the era of
Technology that's borderline insane to
me it was only possible through this
friendship between Hank and Alexi that
it spread through the rest of the world
Hank was also the first person that
proposed the idea that Alexi get paid
for his work I do not have right to
receive money from my game well that
that's criminal kovid actually really
had a huge effect on the way this movie
was shot particularly how few extras
they were allowed to have on set at once
if you notice that a few scenes most
notably the scenes in the Moscow airport
seemed a little bit low on background
actors that's why they also struggled
because their locations got derailed
they had to switch it up due to coven
have you ever been in Moscow Mr Hodges
they couldn't shoot in Moscow so they
ended up shooting in Scotland instead
and they got a lot of great shots in
Aberdeen which is just North of Scotland
because of these huge concrete monoliths
that doubled really well for Moscow
you're not safe until you leave Moscow
go obviously not everything in the film
is going to be a perfect mirror of real
life one of the ways they really
embellished by the end of the writing
process was the car chase through Moscow
in the beginning they were being
metaphorical about it because Hank and
Alexi were under a lot of pressure from
the KGB and the Maxwells in the end
though they thought a car chase would
amp up the stakes it actually ended up
working out for them even with the kova
delays
because they never would have been able
to shoot a car chase scene like that in
Moscow would find a really solid
audience and so I hope that's what
happened the original cut of the film
was about two hours and 10 minutes it
wound up being cut down to about two
hours the scene they ended up losing
were between Hank and Sasha The
Interpreter there was actually a Side
Story between the two characters that
still kinda plays out in the Final Cut
hey don't sacrifice everything for these
but we ended up losing most of it does
anyone have any theories the only other
scene that got lost was when Hank and
Alexi meet over a game of chess that
kinda plays out like a war between the
East and West we come from different
worlds you go back to yours now return
to mine luckily though most
[Music]
to beat your high score in Tetris I
honestly can't believe what an
incredible story is behind such a simple
game Hank and Alexi risked their lives
and brought us a truly iconic game
through the power of their friendship
what was your favorite Tetris moment
[Music]